well if we have so many examples of
unregistered sales of securities
and we have so many examples of
situations where there appears to be
significant fraud associated even with
the largest of these initial coin
offerings a reasonable question to ask
is where's the sec what are they doing
about this
it's a darn good question i wish i had a
good answer
by my count the securities and exchange
commission has brought only six
enforcement actions as of july of 2018
in a situation where there are thousands
of examples of securities fraud
violations involving billions of dollars
i've been publicly quoted as saying this
is the largest violation of the federal
securities laws since the code of
hammurabi interesting question
why is the sec doing nothing
well there's several possible
explanations and i don't know that any
of them is satisfactory
one is that the sec doesn't understand
the magnitude or the nature of this
problem
i find that hard to believe
they read the same newspapers that we do
they can read the same research reports
out of the university of pennsylvania
they can look at the same studies that
the wall street journal has done so the
possibility the sec is include in as to
the nature of these issues strikes me as
implausible
the second possibility is that
developing these cases takes time
if we look at the history of sec
enforcement actions it turns out that on
average from the time the sec begins an
investigation to the time that they
actually bring a proceeding is about 22
months
so it may be that the sec is hard at
work behind the scenes developing a
large number of these cases and that at
some point in the future we're going to
see a deluge of litigation against some
of these icos that haven't been
registered or that are fraudulent
a piece of me hopes that's the case
but i wouldn't exactly bet the farm on
it
third possibility is what i call
strategic surrender by the sec
the sec could stand back and the sec
could say wait a minute
if we brought these cases and if we
prevailed what would we get
we would typically get an injunction
that tells these people not to do it
again
and then we'd get an order that says
return the money
but if many of these people are outside
our jurisdiction
and if it's in crypto in the form of
bitcoin or ether and if we don't have
the ability to track it
then what good is the remedy
well i'm going to argue there are other
ways that we could go at these people
but i understand the sec's argument that
wait a minute
we may not have an effective remedy and
rather than pursue all of these people
in court and get hollow victories
with injunctions that we really can't
enforce we'll use our resources for
something else
another theory is that the sec says hey
wait a minute let the states deal with
it well that's interesting the states
have in fact brought approximately 70
actions
the states have been about 10 times more
active in this area than the securities
exchange commission
but i would ask wait a minute
a lot of this activity is international
a lot of it is national as a practical
matter none of it is localized to texas
or massachusetts you don't find internet
offerings limited to people in austin or
topeka
it's a national phenomenon and if it's a
national phenomenon shouldn't the sec be
on the case
other possibility resource allocation we
only have so many lawyers at the sec
there are only so many frauds that we
can chase you know at any one point in
time so we're going to follow other
things we're going to pursue other
people
that's an interesting point and the
question that i would pose to the sec is
what else are you doing that's so much
more important than pursuing these large
and obvious frauds
which are hitting many people who are
basically mom and pop on main street
don't understand what goes on in the
world in crypto and want to catch a
little piece of the magic all right you
know they want to be as rich as the
people who got in on bitcoin when it was
a nickel and it rose up to twenty
thousand dollars only now to collapse
down to six right they want a piece of
that too and many of them are losing
everything as they're chasing that dream
another possible explanation has a moral
dimension
look at what's going on here
what we have is a bunch of libertarian
crypto anarchists ripping off another
bunch of libertarian crypto anarchists
and we as the united states government
don't want to get in the middle of
one bunch of libertarian crypto
anarchists ripping off other libertarian
crypto anarchists so you guys have fun
i take a little bit of a different
approach here
from my perspective i think it's
important for the sec to assert its
jurisdiction where it legitimately
exists in this area
and if we're up to me and it's not
i'd be filing lots of actions making
relatively straightforward claims that
these are securities they should have
been registered they weren't registered
but in addition to the traditional
remedies of getting the injunction and
an order that says pay back the money
and i know the money's not coming back
i would borrow some techniques from
intellectual property lawyers that
litigate copyright cases over the
internet with great frequency
and what i would do is i'd get a
provision of the injunction
that limits the abilities
of
providers on the internet
right of hosts and of search engines to
post information relating to these
frauds
so you can get a court to issue the
equivalent of a takedown order
saying if this white paper by this
organization
violates this injunction
you then won't be able to find it if you
search for it on google
it won't be allowed to be hosted on
these different places on the internet
all right now
that doesn't stop the fraud i get that
but what it does is it makes the search
costs to find the fraud much higher
and if those search costs are increased
then the number of people who will wind
up investing in that particular fraud
will go down
i agree we're not going to be able to
stop this kind of fraud
but if we make it more difficult and
more expensive for people to perpetrate
the fraud by directing these offers into
the united states
we can take steps to protect people from
obvious scams that are out there